Bueno, pues ya probamos que raíz de 2
es un número irracional,
que te parece si ahora pensamos
en probar, en demostrar
que raíz de "p"
es también un número irracional,
si "p" es un número primo.
Entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí,
"p" es primo, ok.
"p" es un número primo
y lo que quiero probar
es que raíz de "p" es un número irracional.
Y voy a utilizar
algo muy parecido a la demostración
que hice acerca de que de raíz de 2
es un número irracional.
Así que si no has visto el video,
ve a verlo,
no te lo pierdas porque creo que vamos
a utilizar cosas muy parecidas.
"p" es primo y bueno,
vamos a ver que pasa
con la raíz de "p",
quiero analizar
que va a pasar con la raíz de "p",
si es irracional o racional.
Y bueno, voy a seguir la misma idea
que hice en el video pasado
y por lo tanto voy a suponer
que raíz de "p" es un número racional.
Y con esto, voy a ver si puedo llegar a un absurdo
y si llego a un absurdo,
entonces tendré la demostración por contradicción,
si "p" no es un número racional,
entonces debe de ser irracional.
Pero bueno,
como voy a demostrar que raíz de "p",
es un número irracional
y lo voy a demostrar por contradicción,
pues vamos a suponer lo contrario, vamos a suponer que raíz de "p" es racional...
es racional.
Y recuerda que voy a suponer esto
para llegar a la contradicción.
Ahora, si raíz de "p" es racional,
entonces podemos decir que raíz de "p"...
y lo voy a poner con este color...
que raíz de "p" lo podemos ver como  "a",
como "a" entre "b"...
como "a" entre "b", ok,
como una fracción,
donde "a" y "b" son números enteros,
como una razón entre números enteros,
pero de igual manera,
voy a pedir algo muy importante
de esta fracción,
que sea una fracción irreducible,
que ya no se pueda reducir más.
Tú me vas a decir, bueno es que hay fracciones
que si se pueden reducir,
si esta fracción se pudiera reducir,
redúcela todo lo que se puede,
todo lo que se puede, cuantos pasos sean necesarios
hasta obtener una fracción irreducible,
que ya no se puede reducir más
es decir que "a" y "b" sean primos relativos
entre sí o sean co-primos.
Y por lo tanto, esto de aquí...
esto de aquí me va a dar una fracción
que no se puede reducir...
no se puede...
no se puede
reducir...
reducir.
Y de igual manera en la demostración que
raíz de 2 es irracional, aquí está la clave,
aquí hay algo importantísimo para entender
la demostración de que la raíz de "p" es irracional.
Ok, "a" entre "b" no se puede reducir
y eso quiero decir que tanto "a" como "b"
no tienen factores en común,
lo voy a poner aquí...
"a"
y "b"...
y "b"
no tienen factores en común...
no tienen...
tienen factores en común...
factores
en común
excepto 1...
excepto
el 1.
Ok, ahora, ya que se que "a" y "b"
son primos relativos entre sí
y que esta fracción
no se puede reducir,
entonces voy a utilizar
un poco de manipulación algebraica
para decir que "p"...
que "p" lo podemos escribir
como "a" cuadrada...
ok, ¿dónde está el color de "a"?
"a" cuadrada, ok,
lo único que estoy haciendo
es elevando al cuadrado
ambos lados de esta igualdad,
aquí el cuadrado con la raíz se va
y del otro lado me queda "a" cuadrada
entre "b" cuadrada...
entre "b" elevado al cuadrado...
elevado al cuadrado.
Y esto lo escribo así porque de igual manera
como vimos en el video pasado,
de aquí voy a despejar a "a" cuadrada
y entonces voy a decir
que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que poner que "b" cuadrada,
"b" cuadrada por "p",
ok...
por "p"...
y la "p" la voy a poner aquí,
es exactamente lo mismo que "a" cuadrada...
que "a" cuadrada...
lo único que hice fue multiplicar por "b" cuadrada
de ambos lados de esta ecuación,
es decir que "p" por "b" cuadrada
es igual a "a" cuadrada, ok.
¿Y eso de qué me sirve?
¡Ah! porque aquí
lo que me está diciendo, es que "a"...
a ver, lo voy a poner así...
de aquí puedo concluir que "a" cuadrada,
éste de aquí, es un múltiplo de "p"...
es un múltiplo de "p".
¿Y cómo podemos saber eso?
Bueno, se nota desde aquí, si yo tengo a "p"
multiplicado por un número entero y "b" cuadrada
es un número entero, entonces esto
me da un múltiplo de "p"
y si esto es igual a "a" cuadrada,
eso quiere decir que "a" cuadrada,
es un múltiplo de "p", ok.
Muy parecido
a lo que hicimos en el video pasado,
"a" cuadrada es un múltiplo de "p",
ok y entonces esto quiere decir que "a"
es múltiplo de "p",
pues veamos...
Imagínate que yo tengo aquí a "a",
"a" va de color salmón
entonces aquí voy a poner "a"
y voy a descomponer en factores primos a "a",
entonces si yo pongo la descomposición
en factores primos de "a",
supongamos que es...
para no ponerle "p" de primo voy a ponerle,
"f", "f1" es un primo, "f2" es otro primo,
"f3" es otro primo
y recuerda que todo número
lo podemos descomponer en factores primos
hasta llegar a "fn",
todos estos son números primos
y es lo que vale "a".
A "a" lo estoy factorizando en números primos,
Ahora, ¿cómo podríamos escribir
a "a" cuadrada ya teniendo esto de aquí?
Bueno, pues "a" cuadrada es exactamente lo mismo
y podré decir que esto es...
déjame copiar y pegar para
que no se haga tan largo todo esto,
lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar éste dos veces,
así que lo voy a poner una vez por aquí, ok,
y lo voy a poner otra vez por aquí, ok,
vamos a ver si sí me cabe o no...
no, no me cabe...
entonces lo que voy a hacer,
es mover un poco éste de aquí...
vamos a moverlo...
ok, éste de aquí lo voy a mover un poco...
ctrl + x...
y ahora lo voy a mover un poco...
lo voy a mover para acá, ok...
"a" cuadrada lo puedo ver así,
estos multiplicando a estos,
así que voy a tomar a estos de aquí
y los voy a mover para acá...
ya, perfecto, ahora si me caben...
Y lo que estoy haciendo es tomándome "a" cuadrada
y "a" cuadrada es lo mismo que "a" por "a",
o espera, y por lo tanto es lo mismo que estos
que multiplican a su vez a estos mismo.
Y bueno, inclusive lo podríamos
acomodar de la siguiente manera,
podríamos decir que "a" cuadrada
es exactamente lo mismo, ok,
que...
y vamos a acomodarlo así...
que "f1"...
"f1" por "f1", ok, por "f2" por "f2", ok,
ésta es una "f", ok,
y a estos puntitos
vamos a multiplicarlos por todos los demás
y después por "fn" por "fn".
Ahora, lo que quiero que veas es que aquí dice,
justo aquí dice que "a" cuadrada
tiene como uno de los factores,
como uno de todos estos primos a "p",
si "a" cuadrada lo podemos ver como "p",
que multiplica a "b" cuadrada,
entonces "p" debe de ser alguno de todos estos,
podría ser éste de aquí o no sé,
éste de aquí o no sé, éste de aquí...
alguno de todos estos
tiene que ser forzosamente "p",
porque a "a" cuadrada lo podemos ver de esta manera
y "p" es un número primo,
por lo tanto, supongamos que éste es "p",
digo, no sé bien cual sea el valor de "p"
pero vamos a suponer que éste es "p",
si éste es "p", entonces "f2" también es "p", ok,
y de igual manera si es "f1" ó "fn" ó "f3"
el que tú quieras tomar.
Si "f2" es "p", entonces "f2" también es "p"
y eso quiero decir que "a"...
"a" también tiene como factor a "p", porque aquí está
"f2"  y entonces aquí justo es el momento
en donde vamos a poder concluir
y déjame ponerlo aquí,
vamos a poder concluir que
"a" es múltiplo de "p"...
es múltiplo de "p"
y esto es importantísimo,
"a" es múltiplo de "p" porque
tiene a "p"
como un factor,
cuando descomponemos a "a" en números primos
o dicho de otra manera,
podríamos decir que a "a"...
vamos a ponerlo aquí...
a "a" lo puedo ver como un cierto número...
le voy a poner "k"...
"k" por "p"...
por "p", ok.
Si "a" es múltiplo de "p",
entonces podemos ver a
"a" como "k" por "p".
Ok, una vez que ya tenemos
que éste es un posible valor para "a",
vamos a sustituirlo justo aquí
y vamos a hacer lo mismo que hicimos
cuando nosotros tomamos la raíz de 2,
voy a sustituir éste de aquí,
aquí, a ver que me queda.
Y me quedaría que "p" por "b2"...
ok, ¿dónde está el color de "b"?
aquí...
por "b" cuadrada es
exactamente lo mismo que "a" cuadrada,
pero "a" cuadrada lo podemos
ver como "kp" elevado al cuadrado...
aquí adentro voy a poner a "k" por "p"...
a "k" por "p", ok,
y bueno, si yo elevo al
cuadrado a esto,
me va a quedar que esto es exactamente lo mismo
que "p" cuadrada por "k" cuadrada...
"k" cuadrada por "p" cuadrada,
estoy distribuyendo este cuadrado...
y de este lado tengo a "p" por "b" cuadrada...
a "p" por "b" cuadrada,
¿y de aquí qué crees que voy a hacer?
Bueno, pues lo que voy a hacer
es despejar a "b" cuadrada
y para esto que te parece si divido todo entre "p",
entonces me va a quedar que "b" cuadrada...
me va a quedar que "b" cuadrada
lo podemos ver como "k" cuadrada...
"k" cuadrada por "p"...
por "p"...
y esto porque estoy dividiendo todo entre "p".
Ok, y con esto estoy diciendo...
entonces con esto...
y déjame poner aquí una flecha
para que no nos confundamos,
que "b" cuadrada...
"b" cuadrada es múltiplo de "p"...
múltiplo de "p" y estoy diciendo esto
por la misma razón que "a" cuadrada
es múltiplo de "p",
porque podemos escribir a
"a" cuadrada
como "p" por "b" cuadrada
y aquí a "b" cuadrada
la podemos escribir como "k" cuadrada por "p"
y si "b" cuadrada es múltiplo de "p",
eso quiere decir que...
déjame ponerlo para acá arriba...
eso quiere decir que "b" es múltiplo...
múltiplo de "p"...
de "p"...
y justo en este momento
es donde cae la contradicción,
no se puede que "a" sea múltiplo de "p"
y que "b" sea múltiplo de "p"
y que ésta sea
una fracción irreducible,
porque precisamente habíamos dicho
que "a" y "b" no tienen factores
en común excepto el 1 y "p" no es 1
porque es un número primo
y acabamos de ver que tanto "a" como "b"
tienen como factor a "p"
y con esto llegamos a la contradicción,
no puede pasar
que no tengan factores en común
y tengan como factor a "p",
entonces es justo en este momento
donde ya podemos concluir
que la raíz de "p", no debe de ser racional...
déjame quitar esto de aquí...
no debe de ser racional, la raíz de "p"
debe de ser forzosamente irracional...
irracional,
que es justo lo que queríamos probar.
Si nosotros llegamos a una contradicción
suponiendo que la raíz de "p" es racional,
entonces tenemos que decir
que la raíz de "p" es irracional,
que era justo al resultado
que queríamos llegar.
De lujo.